WE'RE GOING TO OF START OUR
MEETINGUTILITY AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR WHO IS HERE
WE HAVE TO MEMBERS THAT WOULD
GET US TO A QUORUM I WAS HOPING
THAT WE NEED ONE MORE -- SO THAT
WE CAN JUMP RIGHT INTO THE THE
MEAT OF THIS BUT MR CHIU IF
YOU'D LIKE.
TO COME FORWARD YOU HAVE A. B.
SEVEN THAT'S BEFORE US
[inaudible]
TODAY
.
RECOMMENDATION -- FROM THE
COMMITTEES TO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
HEY YOU CAN BEGIN.
THANK YOU I WAS GONNA MISS
RICHARD THING FROM THE MEMBER.
NOW I ARE HERE 2% A. B. SEVEN
WHICH WAS SET CALIFORNIA ON
DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME ALL YEAR
ROUND.
PENDING FEDERAL APPROVAL.
IF PASSED THIS BILL WILL GO INTO
EFFECT THE MARCH FOLLOWING THE
FEDERAL AUTHORIZED THE XIN.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA VOTERS EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT TO ELIMINATE THE BI
ANNUAL TYING SWITCH -- WITH THE
MORE MORE THAN 60% APPROVAL OF
THE BALLOT MEASURE AUTHORIZING
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THIS
ISSUE THAT'S WHY WORK HERE.
AND DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME WAS
ADOPTED DURING THE WAR TIME TO
SAVE ENERGY HARDLY EVER DID
RESEARCH SHOWS THE THE ENERGY
CONSUMPTION PATENT HAS CHANGED.
LOCAL BOOK QUITE A BIT IN AND
THE LAST.
YEARS -- DOES PRACTICE IS NO
LONGER A DOES SHOW.
AND ASKED TO COME MEDIA ANALYSIS
POINT OUT YOU'RE WRONG DAYLIGHT
SAVING TIME COULD EVEN HAVE
POTENTIAL POSITIVE IN THE G.
IMPACT. FOR THE ALIGNMENT OF
SOLAR PRODUCTION.
ADDITIONALLY A STUDY HOW.
LONG SHOWN THE NEGATIVE EFFECT
OF BI ANNUAL TIME SWITCH
INCLUDING THE INCREASE TRAFFIC
AND TO WORKPLACE ACCIDENT.
HEART ATTACK A STROKE AND OWN ON
ON THE DAY FOLLOWING THIS SPRING
FORWARD.
SO WE WE ARE NOT ALONE IN
CONSIDERING THIS PRACTICE.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN AFTER
CALL TWENTY OF HOUSE TO OF
PROSTITUTION. SEVEN THIRTY NINE
EIGHT ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION
EXPRESSING INTEREST IN
ELIMINATING THE BI ANNUAL TIMES
WHICH INCLUDING OUR NEIGHBORS.
OR ARE ON OREGON AND AND AND
THEIR NEIGHBORS TO WASHINGTON
STATE.
DOES YOUR THREE DIFFERENT PIECES
ALL FEDERAL LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED. TWO PLAYS TO COUNTY
ON DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME YOU'RE
WRONG OR GIVEN THE STAYED THE
DISCRETION TO CHOOSE STANDARD
TIME MORE DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME.
ALRIGHT STATE RECORDS AND MY MY
A OF STATE REPRESENTATIVE ROLE
CONNER.
IS A CO SPONSOR OF ALL ONE OF
THE BUILDING AND INTRODUCED IN
THE HOUSE A REPRESENT A
REPRESENTATIVES.
AND MARCO RUBIO PHAM OF FLORIDA
IS ALSO AUTHORED A BILL IN THE
SENATE.
AND LAST YEAR.
THIS BODY PASS A BILL TO ALLOW
VOTERS TO CONSIDER.
THE PRACTICE OFFICE REGION OR
CLOCK.
AND THE VOTER HAS SPOKEN.
I AM I WITH ME TODAY AND BY THE
A JOINT AUTHOR.
AS THE MISTER.
BUT OBERNOLTE YOU HAVE A CLUE
HOW MUCH -- IF WE COULD BEFORE
YOU MAKE YOUR COMMENTS SENATE
MEMBER WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO
LET'S.
START WITH MARK FUHRMAN THERE
WILL BE READY.
TO MOVE OUT.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN PRESENT PATTERSON.
BURKE -- CARE CARILLO CHAN.
CHAN HERE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
KING [inaudible]
OUR COMMUNITY.
OKAY BILLS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED -- WILL TURN TO YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M A PROUD TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR
OF THE OF AB SEVEN ASSEMBLYMAN
SHE WHAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR FOUR YEARS NOW THIS
ISSUE -- AND IT'S REALLY
GRATIFYING TO SEE IT HAVE COME
THIS FAR.
THIS BEING UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE I WANTED TO AMPLIFY
SOME OF THE ASSEMBLYMAN COMMENTS
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL ENERGY
SAVINGS THAT THIS ACTION COULD
UNLOCK.
I'M SURE WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR ON
THIS COMMITTEE WITH A DARKER --
THAT THE FACT THAT WE OVER
PRODUCE RENEWABLES DURING THE
DAYLIGHT HOURS AND UNDER PRODUCE
THEM IN THE EVENING HOURS.
WHEN DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIME WAS
FIRST INSTITUTED THE PEAK ENERGY
CONSUMPTION OCCURRED DURING THE
AFTERNOON ESPECIALLY IN THE
SUMMER MONTHS WHEN EVERYONE RAN
THEIR AIR CONDITIONERS BUT AS A
VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION NOW NOW
WE HAVE THIS PROBLEM?
WHERE WE ARE UNDER PRODUCING
RENEWABLES IN THE EVENING WHEN
PEOPLE ARE TURNING ON THEIR
LIGHTS SO THAT'S WHY SWITCH TO
DAYLIGHT SAVINGS TIMES FULL TIME
WELL REALLY -- HELP WITH THAT
SITUATION FACT THE LATEST
FIGURES THAT I'VE SEEN SAY THAT
A SHIFT TO FULL TIME DAYLIGHT
SAVINGS TIME WILL SAVE.
ABOUT A THREE THOUSAND MEGAWATT
HOURS OF ELECTRICITY EVERY DAY
THAT WILL SAVE CALIFORNIA
REPAIRS OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS -- IN
ELECTRICITY CHARGES EVERY YEAR
IN ADDITION TO HELPING.
OUR STATE MEDIA IT'S CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I THINK THAT THE
TIME HAS COME FOR THIS CHANGE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
ANYONE FROM THE AUDIENCE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL SAY NONE AT OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONSMISTER MAYES.
I JUST WANT TO SAY I THINK THIS
IS A FANTASTIC BILL IT'S LONG
OVERDUE THANK YOU GUYS FOR DOING
THE WORK -- I WOULD LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
IF YOU'D.
THANK YOU BE INTERESTED.
YES THANK YOU YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB FOR SYSTEM PAYS OFF
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD -- TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THAT
COULD COME OUT OF THIS AS WELL --
WE HAVE A MOTION -- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR A ROLL
CALL.
AB SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE FLOOR HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
AYE AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE.
I CARILLO.
CHEN.
CHEN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CUTTING [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
HI MAYES AYE MARRIAGE TO G.
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
AS REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO ON EIGHTEEN THERE ARE
SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR -- WE ARE
ONE SHORT QUOTED ON CALL THE
PLACE THAT I CALL UNTIL WE GET A
SOME MORE MEMBERS TO SHOW UP
UNLESS MR CHEN WAS TO REVISIT.
RESEARCHERS CENTER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF ITEMS ON
CONSENT IS OUR MOTION TO APPROVE
THE CONSENT.
WE HAVE -- THREE THAT'S A. B.
TEN EIGHTY THREE BURKE -- A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN HOLDEN -- WITH
AMENDMENTS.
YEAH IT'S BEEN MOVING.
THIS IS CLEAR FIND BEFORE THE
ROLL CALL.
OF THAT WE HAVE -- HOLDEN --
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN THAT'S A WITH.
TO THE THAT THAT NO AMENDMENTS
THERE AND THEN OF COURSE --
SEVENTY EIGHT ACR.
SEVENTY EIGHT HOW FOR THE FOUR
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THIRTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ACR -- SEVENTY EIGHT AND THAT IS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
ROLL CALL.
AB TEN EIGHTY THREE SUCH CONSENT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CONSENT.
AND A. B.. FIFTEEN THIRTEEN IT'S
TO PASS THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CONSENT AND ACR
SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE I CAMILLE.
CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK.
REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TEAM. EIGHT VOTES OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN -- WILL.
WILL NOW TURN -- TO OR
INFORMATIONAL -- ITEM.
NO ACTION TO BE TAKEN ON THIS
BUT WE WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE TO PRESENT -- A. B. ELEVEN
FORTY THREE QUIRK THIS IS A
ENERGY RENEWABLE GAS PROGRAM.
NUMBER THEN -- TO BE SURE.
THANKS FOR THAT -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE
ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR CORRECT
DOCTOR QUIRK WOULD LIKE TO THINK --
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH HIS OFFICE AND OUR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO IMPROVE
THIS MEASURE.
HIS MOTIVATION AND WANTING TO
PRESENT TODAY IS TO START A
CONVERSATION DOCTOR QUIRK WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT HE WILL BE LIMITING
THIS BILL TO RENEWABLE GAS
PRODUCED IN STATE.
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE WITH
LEVERAGE EXISTING UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DEVELOP A MORE
RESILIENT AND COMPREHENSIVE DE
CARBONIZATION STRATEGY FOR
BUILDINGS WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
HELPING A CHEAP ORGANIC WEEKS
WASTE DIVERSION SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
AND AIR QUALITY GOALS.
THIS MEASURE CREATES A PROGRAM
TO INCENTIVIZE CUSTOMERS TO USE
RENEWABLE GASES FOOLS FUELS
INCLUDING RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN AND RENEWABLE
PROPANE INSTEAD OF FOSSIL FUELS.
I IN ITS MOST RECENT SCOPING
PLANNING CALIFORNIA RUSHES OF
RESOURCES BOARD STATED THAT WE
MUST MOVE TOWARDS CLEANER
HEATING FUELS.
THIS STARTS WITH EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND REDUCTION INCLUDING
BUILDING AN APPLIANCE
ELECTRIFICATION WHERE THESE
ADVANCE ADVANCEMENTS MAKE SENSE
AND INCLUDING USING MORE
RENEWABLE GAS.
REPLACING FOSSIL FUELS WILL WITH
RENEWABLE GAS CAN REDUCE POTENT
SO SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS AND STATE POLICY
SHOULD SUPPORT IN THIS EFFORT.
USING DEMAND FOR NATURAL GAS AND
MOVING TOWARDS RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS WELL CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS
TWENTY THIRTY CLIMATE TARGETS
TESTIFYING ANSWERING TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WITH ME TODAY IS NINA
COMPORT WITH THE COALITION FOR
NOBLE NATURAL GAS.
AND TIM CARMICHAEL A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN HOLDEN
AND MEMBERS IN A COOPER AND THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND WITH
THE SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE
DESCRIBED BUILDING D.
CARBONIZATION HAS BECOME A KEY
CLIMATE PRIORITY FOR THE STATE
WHILE THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS EXPLICITLY
RECOMMENDED A TWO PRONGED
STRATEGY.
OF BOTH APPLIANCE
ELECTRIFICATION AND THE USE OF
RENEWABLE GAS THAT'S FAR THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ONLY DIRECTED
STATE AGENCIES TO PURSUE A
APPLIANCE ELECTRIFICATION.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE TO
FOCUS ON ELECTRIFICATION AS AN
EXCITING AND EMERGING
OPPORTUNITY BUT RENEWABLE GAS
ALSO HAS A SIGNIFICANT ROLE TO
PLAY IN THE SECTOR.
SPECIFICALLY A RENEWABLE GAS IS
AVAILABLE TODAY TO BE USED TO DE
CARBONIZED EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE ORIGINALLY BUILT
TO TRANSPORT FASA NATURAL GAS.
DEVELOPMENT EVER NOBLE GAS FROM
ORGANIC WASTE RESOURCES IS
CRITICAL IF WE ARE TO ACHIEVE
THE STATE START OF CLIMATE
PUTTING CALLS.
AND SCENARIO WORK BY NAVIGANT
CONSULTING CLEARLY SHOWS THAT
I'M PLAYING RENEWABLE GAS ALONG
SIDE ELECTRIFICATION WHERE
APPROPRIATE CAN LEAD TO MORE
COST EFFECTIVE OUTCOMES IN THE
BUILDING SECTOR.
AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO OVER NOBLE GAS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS FOR
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMERS.
AS YOUR EXCELLENT COMMITTEE
BACKGROUND DOCUMENT POINTS OUT
THE CC IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NOTED
THAT RENEWABLE GAS SHOULD BE
DIRECTED TO NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
IN THE SHORT TERM.
WE'RE PLEASED TO REPORT TODAY
THAT WE ARE APPROACHING A 100%
SATURATION IN THE VEHICLE SPACE.
AND YET WE STILL HAVE A GREAT
VOLUME OF METHANE WE NEED TO
FIND A HOME FOR IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR STATUTORY REQUIREMENT OF A
40% REDUCTION BY.
TWENTY THIRTY USING IT TO
DISPLAY SOME OF THE ONE TRILLION
CUBIC FEET OF NATURAL GAS THAT
WE USE IN OUR BUILDINGS TODAY IS
A COMMON SENSE PLACE TO START.
WE APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEES WINE IS TO WORK WITH
US IN THE INTERIM TO DESIGN AN
OPTIMAL CONSUMER FACING PROGRAM.
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MEMBERS MIGHT HAVE
TODAY AND IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS AHEAD THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDEN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE TIM
CARMICHAEL IS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY.
IN THE FIRST TECH GO ON IN HIS
COMMENTS ABOUT -- OUR P. SHE XIN --
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR IN CHAIRS
OFFICE ON THIS ISSUE AND
RECOGNIZING THAT -- HOPEFULLY
MANY MORE DISCUSSIONS TO COME
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR --%
SO CAL GAS IS AN ARDENT
SUPPORTER OF RENEWABLE GASES --
WE HAVE A TEAM WORKING ON
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS WE HAVE A
TEAM WORKING ON HYDROGEN --
EFFORTS WE SEE -- BOTH OF THESE
AS INTEGRAL TO THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY.
STRATEGY -- OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
LOT OF BUZZ ABOUT
ELECTRIFICATION AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
WITH BATTERIES AND ELECTRICITY
BUT WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE A
PORTFOLIO APPROACH.
WHETHER YOUR GOAL IS
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS --
RESILIENCY IN OUR ENERGY SYSTEM.
COST SAVINGS FOR ONE OF OUR BIG
CHALLENGES THAT I THINK THERE'S
A GROWING AWARENESS ABOUT IS
WHAT WE GONNA DO ABOUT ENERGY
STORAGE -- BATTERIES ARE
DEFINITELY GONNA PLAY A ROLE BU
ARE THEY GOING TO MEET ALL THE
NEEDS AND THEIR I THINK THERE'S
A GROWING AWARENESS NOT ONLY IN
IN EUROPE BUT ACROSS AMERICA.
THAT -- WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
OTHER -- LONGER TERM ENERGY
STORAGE OPTIONS AND RENEWABLE
GASES WE BELIEVE COMPLACENT
AFRICAN ROLE IN THAT.
THERE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN
THE BRIEFING PAPER THAT I JUST
WANT.
TO SPEAK TO A A COUPLE OF THOSE --
THERE.
THERE'S THERE'S A BROAD QUESTION
ABOUT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO MOVE
AHEAD WITH THIS EFFORT AT THIS
TIME ARE THERE OTHER -- EFFORTS
THAT NEED TO PLAY OUT FIRST
RATHER LEGISLATION THAT NEEDS TO
PLAY OUT FIRST BEFORE WE MOVE
AHEAD WITH.
A STRATEGY LIKE THIS A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS APPROACH -- DEVELOPING A
CONSUMER ORIENTED INCENTIVE FOR
THE USE OF A NOBLE GASES IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO AT OTHER
EFFORTS UNDER WAY.
VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE EFFORTS
THAT ARE ACTIVE RIGHT NOW ARE
INCENTIVES TO PRODUCE --
RENEWABLE GASES IN CALIFORNIA
NOT NECESSARILY TO CONSUME THEM
AND NOT DIRECTED AT THE THE
CONSUMERS AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE BOTH.
JUST LIKE WE'VE DONE OVER TIME
IN THE RENEWABLE ENERGY SPACE WE
HAD INCENTIVES TO PURGE TO
PRODUCE MORE SOLAR AND WIND AND
WE INCENTIVES FOR CONSUMERS. TO
TO BUY THAT -- THAT ENERGY OR
THAT ELECTRICITY GENERATED FROM
THE SOURCES -- ONE OTHER POINT I
WANT TO MENTION -- RELATES TO A
COMMENT IN REFERENCE TO AB
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO WHICH IS A
MISS FRIEDMAN BILL FROM LAST
YEAR.
THIS IS A THE REFERENCE IN THE
IN THE BRIEFING PAPER IT.
WE THANK -- CONTINUES A COMMON
MISPERCEPTION ABOUT A FEW BILLS
THAT PASSED IN THE LAST YEAR.
TO THEY WERE AND IF YOU IF YOU
LOOK AT THE THE LANGUAGE THEY
ARE -- AND D. CARBONIZATION OF
BUILDING DE CARBONIZATION BILLS.
THE AGENCY SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES HAVE CHOSEN
TO FOCUS ON BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION.
BUT THE LEGISLATION -- THAT
PASSED WAS BUILDING D.
CARBONIZATION.
UNDER THAT UMBRELLA WE THINK
WE'RE NOBLE GASES ARE -- TODAY
AND CAN BE AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY
FOR BUILDING D. CARBONIZATION
ELECTRIFICATION IS ONE STRATEGY.
NOBLE GASES IS ANOTHER STRATEGY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR YOUR
ATTENTION THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE.
TO HELLO AND THEIR THEIR VOICE.
TO THE SUBJECT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AND YOUR AUNTS WEEK HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN PROPANE
GAS ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR THROUGH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE INCLUDING
RENEWABLE PROPANE.
AND WHAT'S ENVISIONED A FOR THIS
BILL GOING FORWARD WE'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO BE A STAKEHOLDER AS
A CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE INTO
NEXT YEAR.
WE SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KATE ON WHO
DROWNED THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MATT
CRIMMINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHERS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK WITH HER.
OKAY WILL WELCOME YOU.
THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE BILL BUT APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS -- INTEREST IN ENGAGING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN THE FALL TO
PAY BETTER ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE.
BOB I AM I THINK IS A VALUABLE
RESOURCE IN CALIFORNIA TO BOTH
REDUCE OUR METHANE EMISSIONS AND
DISPLAYS FOSSIL FUEL USE ALL THE
HOUSES WE'VE REVIEWED.
SO FAR IDENTIFY THAT THERE'S AN
EXTREMELY LIMITED SUPPLY BY
METHANE RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S DEMAND FOR METHANE
GAS.
AND THAT SOME OF THE SOURCES ARE
VERY HIGH COST WE NEED TO GET
CLEAR ON HOW MUCH REALLY EXISTS
AT WHAT COST AND IMPORTANTLY
WHAT THE BEST USE OF THIS
LIMITED RESOURCE AS FAR AS THE
EYE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT.
THERE SEVERAL ONGOING PROCESS
THE THAT SHOULD PROVIDE MORE
INSIGHT ON THESE QUESTIONS.
THE CZ IS EXPECTED TO RELEASE
RESULTS FROM THE EPIC FUNDED
STUDIES STRATEGIC ASSESSMENT OF
THE LONG TERM ROLE OF NATURAL
GAS IN CALIFORNIA LATER THIS
YEAR.
THE CBC'S ALSO ASSESSING OPTIONS
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
BUILDINGS BY 40% BY TWENTY
THIRTY AS DIRECTED IN AB THIRTY
TO THIRTY TWO AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER.
WHICH IS PART OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN I PER AND IN ADDITION
THERE SHOULD BE A PC ACTIVITY TO
CONSIDER BY A MYTH THAT METHANE
PROCUREMENT.
AS DIRECTED BY SB FOURTEEN FORTY
WORK WERE WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
AS YEAH AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE
PRE JUDGES THE RESULT IN
IMPLICATIONS OF THESE EFFORTS
WHICH MIGHT END UP WORKING AT
CROSS PURPOSES WITH OTHER STATE
POLICY.
POLICY THAT ARE AIMED AT
REDUCING DEPENDENCE ON GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING THROUGH BOTH THESE
EXISTING FORMS AND WHAT THE
AUTHOR AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS --
ON TOPICS RELATED TO BEST USING
CALIFORNIA'S METHANE AND BY MATH
AND RESOURCES THANK YOU.
AND THEN MICHAEL BOOKER ON
BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATIONAL TRYING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF A BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE -- OUR CLIENTS
REPRESENT -- FOLKS THAT ARE NOT
ONLY IN THE BUSINESS OF
DEVELOPING BY METHANE PROJECTS
AND SO WERE HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE.
THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE OF THAT
BY A METHANE THOSE S.
TRANSPORTATION FUEL NOT FOR USE
IN BUILDINGS NOT FOR USE IN
HOMES NOT FOR USE IN BUSINESSES.
BUSINESS COMMUNITY CAN'T AFFORD
TO USE BY METHANE IN OUR
FACTORIES PERIOD.
IT'S FIVE TEN FIFTEEN TIMES AS
EXPENSIVE.
AS RENEWED AS CONVENTIONAL
NATURAL GAS SO IT'S NOT AN
OPTION FOR US AND WON'T BE AN
OPTION FOR US.
AND THAT GETS LOST IN THIS
DEBATE A LOT IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE I THINK
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS ARE
GOING TO BE CONSIDERING AT SOME
POINT THIS YEAR.
IS COST CONCERNS ABOUT ELECT
RISING ELECTRICITY PRICES FROM
ALL OF THE ISSUES RELATED TO
WILD FIRE.
AND IT IS GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO ELECTRIFY BUILDINGS
GOING FORWARD IF OUR ELECTRICITY
PRICES ARE SUPER HIGH.
BUT USING BIO METHANE AND
BUILDINGS THAT HAS THE EXACT
SAME EMISSIONS PROFILE.
DOES CONVENTIONAL NATURAL GAS SO
IT'S NOT A SOLUTION TO REDUCE CO
TWO FROM BUILDINGS.
NOT NOW NOT TEN YEARS FROM NOW
AND IT'S NOT COST EFFECTIVE
FORCE WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF IT
DON'T GET ME WRONG MY DERRY'S
ARE PRODUCING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF BY METHANE.
IT'S ALL GOING INTO
TRANSPORTATION FEEL AND IT HAS A
VERY VALUABLE BENEFITS THEY'RE
NOT ONLY REDUCES NOTHING ITS
CARBON NEGATIVE.
IT ALSO HAS A TREMENDOUS BENEFIT
WHEN REPLACES DIESEL IS
TRANSPORTATION FEEL.
GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE FIFTY MILLION
GALLONS.
EXCUSE ME DIESEL GALA QUOTE ONCE
ARE GONNA BE PRODUCED BY JERRY
BIO DIED JESTERS.
IN THE NEAR TERM.
USING THAT AND HEAVY DUTY
FREIGHT AS A REPLACEMENT FOR
DIESEL.
WILL REDUCE EMISSIONS OF KNOX BY
ELEVEN HUNDRED TONS PER YEAR.
ABOUT THREE TONS PER DAY IT'S
HUGE IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT
THAT'S THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE
OF BY A METHANE.
NOT FOR REPLACEMENT OF NATURAL
GAS AND HOMES BUILDINGS ARE
BUSINESSES.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE.
TO A SURE THEIR THOUGHTS ON THIS
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS.
HEARING NONE AND SEEN ON ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE TO THE WITNESS.
WELL THANK YOU AGAIN MISS WORK
YOU'VE STEPPED IN AND THANK YOU
FOR ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES WE
AGAIN.
YEAH.
YOUR OFFICIAL DESIGNATED HITTER.
BUT I THINK IT IS AN IMPORTANT
SUBJECT AND AS WE SHARED WITH
DOCTOR QUIRK -- WHEN WE WERE
VIEW AND THEN -- ANALYZING THE
BILL THAT THERE IS OPPORTUNITY --
FOR FURTHER REVIEW AND
EVALUATION OF THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF A RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND
HOW THAT COULD BE INNER
INTEGRATED -- BUT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
MOVING PARTS AND SO WE
APPRECIATE -- WHO IS WORKING
WITH US -- AND ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES -- OVER THE NEXT YEAR --
WE WILL -- THIS.
HAVING THE ITEM ON THE AGENDA
TODAY AS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IS ALSO.
TO INDICATE OUR INTERESTED AND
WANTED TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE AND
TO BE ABLE TO GIVE IT.
TO THE APPROPRIATE CONVERSATION
THAT IT'S IT'S A DESERVE.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING IF
YOU HAVE ANY I JUST WANT IT
REALLY QUICKLY I'LL JUST RESPOND
A LITTLE BIT TO THE OPPOSITION --
FIRST OBVIOUSLY WE ALL KNOW DR
COURT TO BE VERY PRICE SENSITIVE
SO I THINK THAT ANYTHING THAT
COMES OUT WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT
IT WILL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION ALSO I BELIEVE.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMITTEES.
WILLINGNESS TO EVEN HAVE THE
CONVERSATION I KNOW HIS GOAL IS
NOT TO GET AHEAD.
OF ALL OF THE PROCESS GOING ON
SI PC IS IN THE PROCESS OF SOME
THINGS I WAS WE'VE HEARD OTHERS --
I THINK HIS HOPE IS TO MOVE IN
TANDEM WITH THAT AND I THINK
THIS IS HIS OPPORTUNITY HAVE
THAT IS TO TO BEGIN THAT
CONVERSATION -- AND THEN ON THE
TRANSPORTATION I THINK HE WANTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE REALIZE
THAT NATURAL GAS IS BEING PUSHED
OUT OF THAT TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR AND SO.
THERE ARE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THAT.
ARE USEFUL -- HE BELIEVES THAT
DECOMPOSITION IS SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE AND WILL GREATLY BENEFIT
FROM A FULL INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE AND WITH THAT.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME OKAY.
ALL RIGHT IN HERE -- WE WERE
GOING TO WE'RE GONNA TURN BACK --
TO A. B. -- SEVEN WE HAVE A AND
GO BACK THROUGH THE ROLE -- FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THAT BILL IS
ON CALL AND THAT'S CHIU DAYLIGHT
SAVINGS TIME.
SO -- WILL CALL THE ROLL -- FOR
MEMBERS TO TAKE A VOTE ON A. B.
[inaudible]
SEVEN UP PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING -- CARILLO
[inaudible]
CARILLO I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
TING.
TING I THE BILL HAS.
PLUS TEN VOTES THE BILL IS OUT --
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
FOR MOMENT FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
AND THEN WE WILL -- WE HAVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM -- ITEMS --
ALL THE ROLE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
AND IT HAS THE REQUISITE VOTES
SO IT IS OUT THIS IS JUST ADDING
ON PATTERSON.
THIS CONSENT YES.
PATTERSON I CARILLO.
CARILLO I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA.
JEAN.
TING HI.
THERE ARE TWELVE VOTES IN FAVOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IT IS ADOPTED BUT WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO AB SEVEN
AND CONSENT WILL OVER THAT OPEN
FOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
[inaudible]
RIGHT FUNDS.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA RECORD THE THE
LAST ROLE AS THE FINAL AND WE
ARE RICHER.
THE OTHER THE OTHER TWO ARE